así que tenemos estos grupos de pelotas
amarillas llamémoslo así o de círculos
amarillos nosotros lo que vamos a hacer
con esto es pensar en diferentes formas
o grupos con los que podemos llegar al
mismo resultado vamos a contar cuántas
de estas hay en cada uno de los grupos 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 tenemos
entonces grupos de 12 pelotas y cómo
puedo pensar el 12 el 12 en diferentes
grupos lo podemos pensar de la siguiente
manera podemos pensar que tenemos 1
tres cuatro grupos de tres cada uno de
estos grupos tiene tres pelotas así es
que podemos pensar que 12
vamos a escribir que 12
es igual a cuatro grupos voy a poner el
color que use para los grupos cuatro
grupos de tres pelotas cada una cuatro
por tres me llevará a doce que es
exactamente esta forma de representarlo
pero también podemos representarlo de
otra manera qué pasa si yo cuento ahora
esto en tres grupos y ahora de manera
vertical tendré 12
tres grupos tres grupos y en cada uno de
estos grupos tendré cuatro círculos
amarillos así es que pondremos también
que tres grupos
tres grupos y cada uno tiene cuatro
círculos amarillos también es igual a 12
tenemos exactamente el mismo número de
círculos amarillos solo que lo estamos
dividiendo en distintos grupos sin
embargo aún tenemos muchas opciones lo
ven no podemos parar solo ahí tenemos
también la posibilidad de tener dos
grupos de seis éste será el grupo número
uno
donde estamos uniendo 6
de estos círculos amarillos y tendremos
el grupo número 2 donde también estamos
uniendo seis de estos círculos amarillos
de tal manera que podemos decir también
que 12 es igual
a dos grupos
dos grupos y cuántos círculos amarillos
tiene cada grupo
12 es igual a 2 por 62 grupos de 6
pelotas o 6 círculos amarillos cada uno
vamos más adelante si nosotros
consideramos entonces que aquí tenemos
dos grupos de seis qué pasa si contamos
ahora seis grupos de dos tendríamos uno
seis grupos de dos de tal manera que
vamos a volver a escribir que seis
grupos de dos
seis grupos
dos pelotas amarillas cada una será
igual a 12
igual que hemos estado manejando en los
diferentes grupos anteriores
una más y estas me gustan porque son muy
sencillas nosotros tenemos aquí todo un
gran grupo de 12 qué pasa si nosotros lo
contamos como tal como un solo grupo de
12 tendremos
todo este grupo junto
y tendremos un solo grupo
de 12 pelotas amarillas vamos a escribir
entonces que un grupo
un solo grupo por 12 pelotas amarillas
cuántas pelotas tenemos en total 12 una
vez más y finalmente 1 que también es
muy muy divertido es esta parte de
seleccionar cada una de estas pelotas o
círculos como un grupo único así es que
será uno
es 4
10 11
y 12 podemos decir entonces que 12
grupos
solo círculo amarillo será igual a 12 de
cualquier manera y de esta manera
tenemos diferentes grupos con pelotas
amarillas o círculos amarillas en cada
uno pero todos y cada uno nos llevará al
número 12